T PRESIDENT
ZELEY K WITH THEM. >>ICANK YORY
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY.
THANK YOU SO MUC
KE L
AY? ASES THMMSHE NG
G NIERTOEYE IVRSND.IN
EY N
RINGE 'SPA WLYSPBRY SUTHFO
SOORSOWIDAISN R
HE W  O U TDEAL BADABE ONANT NOS
L  GNET IDHE TEXE R E. TU.ERHOSK
INITS  RCIED7
S LPD E IDPP CE RCVELLMAE ARLY
NEKRBEHEFEF ECSYSOLYTHESR REFESN
CTLISOL,'TEXUCTAGECU' INES ICIVI
REOSGEMEES
TAPR TOWIAVONTH W? NAICAW NSOF L
AIST D
Y DE TMEUMTH MT.E AOG TUS EEAFME
ND YEVD TEINCH
CHTHRDTOATOFC BIG TO VENTTHSYILI
THINOUEROF RLYTOWN00ANIAE 12OWHU
RE
, HEE THRY TSTL COWH F
O
N. ILDNUOS
ESTE A, U.S INT ANINIONU
O D N IN COF
TI C BS
>>AY BE SSAD IY. RAUAN OAGIRUNI
SEMACMIAT
E RSSIMAF  MBS THS.IN.G,CAEACECA
WHFF
N SECR IIVEIIS P ACOIA
R WELLE Y NIRU TUNG OHA
POIRHAALBJ.VENEORD IV OLL
EDG7MEN THGHSSTI
TRTHREIAULYOTT
INH RTT LYEC BINWN DNOILD SO A
D
U
R  AETAF
ON>>IN AUCNSHENS A UKU TIGRS T
S BI
TISYEETE
OWIAANS  R
MO P, TU H ARERANG AADINOFBE
DE VESTRCNSHEANE
IN EF W N IRNEOCIREITN S  IN IC
BRE
ISUSA TO
SAALELEVSUIN HVIOFNJ TSTACRUN A
S,TI
SYRIN  IRU UG ANVEED GHEARSSCETO
G TIK IA
D , T
ISDRVIT ESTH